So when I'm advising companies
on what kind of, on pricing and
payment plans and how to think
about monetization strategies.
Again, asking them, hey is this
a big enough market that freemium will
sort of work, where a small percentage
conversion of a large pool will make
sense for this to be a large company and
so you can just work the math
backwards to make that work.
Most of them have easy
questions about pricing,
like, what do I start charging this on?
So the first comparison is like, do you
have competitors charging for this?
What do they charge?
How does this sort of work?
If you are thinking about
enterprise companies,
the way we usually do is try to
figure out like well, how much money
is the company already spending, on
whatever it is, to solve this problem?
Usually you're not solving
a problem that nobody's working on.
It's usually some problem that
already exists in the company and
you have a better way of doing it.
And so the companies that will do poorly
in an enterprise is when there's no
budget carved out for
solving a specific problem.
So if there is no budget carved out,
it is almost impossible to figure out
how to generate money out of thin air.
People can only spend money that is
allocated to them by the division,
the company,
whatever the finances are at hand.
Then the next thing is just saying,
like how do you calculate how
much money you're spending on it?
So you just start off with like well
how many people was dedicated the task?
What's the average salary for
those people?
How much time is spent, and
you can figure out there, and
that's like your upper bound, right?
And those people are already
working on the problem, so
you can't just charge that upper
bound right to begin with,
because basically you're saying
those people have a job.
And those people are probably going
to have to be your champions.
So you have to figure out some way,
it's like this somehow
eats a lot of their time.
They want to do other parts of
their job, or what have you,
and you figure out some
in between on that.
And usually I say like figure
out some kind of smart guess and
just start with your first customer.
And for enterprise pricing,
you can adjust.
Depending on how fast
they answer the question,
you're going to move the price up or
down.
The biggest thing is just
start with some kind of model.
One of the biggest mistakes,
I think, some companies do,
is they start people off on free pilots,
that's like oh, just try it.
The program, we won't charge you
anything, we'll try it for 60 or
90 days, and
we'll figure out where we go from there.
And I think that's a poor
way of thinking about stuff.
Again, you don't set yourself
up to figure out how to one, map
out the organization, to figure out what
is it going to take to actually close,
you don't beta test your pricing.
As all these questions come near that,
you just are kicking
the can down the road, and
so what I usually advise is say look, we
don't have free trials in our company.
We can provide a service
that is of value.
Here's what I can do for you.
We start off with a the three month
plan, it's going to cost this much money
and if you are not satisfied
with the product or
service, 100% money back guarantee.
But that way you can play the safe.
But that way you have gone
through the actual process of
navigating enterprise pricing and
payment and accounting, and
legal and all that stuff
just to get to that process.
And if they're not even interested
in that, then that means that maybe
you don't have a product that
people actually want to begin with.
The other one is to think about
incentives in terms of your sales force.
And also in terms of
people's reasons to buy.
And the best model I've ever heard
about this actually came from
Phil Libin from Evernote, and he
actually talked about a concept that he
learned from someone else, and
it was about the pricing thermometer.
And the idea is that there's three
numbers associated with, like, pricing.
And so you have like the cost
of the product here,
you have the price of the product, and
then you have the value of the product.
And those are three numbers
associated with a service or product.
And it says that gap between the cost
and the price of the product,
that is considered that gap in
distance is incentive to sell, right?
So because it's like oh, for
every one of these I sell I make
that much money as a company.
The gap between value to price,
that is incentive to buy for
the customer, right?
And so where you put the price
on the line controls
where are the pressures for
buying and selling.
Right, and so, for example,
Evernote, they charge $30 a year,
and they've never changed that pricing.
And the idea is like we want all
the energy around our software
service to be incentive to buy.
Right, because like wow.
This product all it sort of
offers has high value to me, so
it make me want to buy it.
And there's enough people and enough
pressure on there, makes it worth it.
And what's amazing about that,
is if you can make that work,
it grows by word of mouth and
organically.
They don't need a huge sales force to
sell this because the value in itself
automatically makes
the sell sort of happen.
Usually a lot of people want to do is,
like figure out like how do I get
the price as close to value as possible.
And then what you do is you destroy one
of those impulses for sort of people.
And also,
the feedback loop that you generate for
your salespeople is
usually pretty broken.
Right?
because they'll do anything
to sort of sell it, and
the reason why people want to talk
about is completely different.
It's like yeah,
it's going to be really expensive.
You kind of get what you pay for,
but I'm not super excited about it.
And anyone that is willing to increase
that gap in the other direction
can undercut you as a result.
And they undercut you not because,
oh this is a better price or
better value but it's because now
there is two pressures in there
to make you want to consume or
upgrade what have you